you had some unique improv exercises
that you would do to loosen oh yeah
right yeah well it didn't sack uh let's
come on here and do give me back my seat
yeah he he did yeah yeah give me back my
son warm ransom and he had us all yell
at as loud as we could
yeah did you have something like that
yeah I had something I brought from
Chicago it's called hey Fred Schneider
what are you doing hey fresh water from
the b-52s I think we have a picture of
Fred Schneider from the b-52 that's his
DMV photo yeah he's actually outrageous
yeah and so how does that work how's
that game work okay well you go like
though everybody's playing we'll go like
hey Fred Schneider what are you doing
and then you know when it's your turn
you'll be like I'm kissing a meatball
under the sea
you know Fred matter
what are you doing I'm shaving my head
and looking in the mirror how long would
you do that for too long
it actually sounds like a lot of fun you
want to play that's sure yeah okay okay
I'll start you want to go next you feel
like you got it sure sure sure yeah yeah
yeah so we all go or do you want to go
yeah hey Fred Schneider what are you
doing I'm asking the Queen to make me a
pie I just robbed a pirate with the
t-shirt cannon this is a real I'm
actually a bizarre weirdo like internet
fan of Paul and Paul in was absolutely
hilarious right my favorite one of him
is like it's like what does it say he's
like Paul we all know what we say when a
man goes overboard Man Overboard
what do we say when a woman goes
overboard full steam ahead
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
on the squares right wasn't that a great
clip subscribe to my youtube channel for
an endless supply of me
[Laughter]